hallo mein Name ist willkommen meine
Damen und Herren ich darf euch heute
recht herzlich willkommen heißen zu
einem Video in dem ich ICQ Spiele
spielen werde ich habe vor real so ein
bisschen die Vermutung bzw vielleicht
sogar die Befürchtung
dass sehr viele von euch als Youtube gar
nicht kennen werden weil ihr
wahrscheinlich zu jung dafür seid oder
weil er damit generell nichts anfangen
könnt oder das einfach auch vielleicht
damals nie benutzt habt als ich
allerdings jung war und damit meine ich
wirklich so vierte fünfte sechste siebte
8 Klasse war als die Q so der einzige
Weg um wirklich mit seinen Freunden
online zu chatten
[Musik]
es gab noch Knuddels und
schülervorzelten so ein Krams aber es
gab noch lange keinen Instagram WhatsApp
snapchat oder etwaige andere soziale
Netzwerke und das geile an als die Q war
dass man nicht nur miteinander chatten
konnte so wie beispielsweise bei
Whatsapp sondern man konnte auch Spiele
spielen wir beispielsweise super Lula
allein diese Musik
ich kriege das Grinsen nicht aus dem
Gesicht auch mal überlegen dass ich
dieses Video hier seit Jahren
aufnehmen wollte
aber ich habe das nirgendwo gefunden und
diese Server funktioniert noch gefühlt
nur einmal im Monat und jetzt habe ich
gerade so ein Moment erwischt wo es
funktioniert wir klicken jetzt einfach
mal auf quick Game er schaut auch dieser
Affe und der die denn oh mein Gott das
war so und der Elefant und das echt
können heulen
das ist so das ist so das Handy für mich
gerade allein wie lange hier für ein
Gegner sucht ne das heißt schon nichts
Gutes zehn Stunden später oh mein Gott
ich habe ihn
oh mein Gott
oh mein Gott mir fällt gerade auf ihr
seht gar nicht alles ich hoffe mal dass
es so passt Freunde wir fangen an ähm ja
ich habe diese Arten von Kugeln die
lilanen und mein Gegner die roten und
jetzt muss ich so wie beim Billard die
Kugeln vom Gegner
rauskicken und jetzt ist der Gegner dran
und der kriegt jetzt halt meine Kugeln
raus
[Musik]
gekickt
ich glaube das wird bei ganz vielen
gerade total wird ankommen aber für mich
sind diese ganzen Animationen auch diese
Spielfeld das ist für mich einfach
das war meine Kindheit dicker ich
versuche jetzt mal den roten hier
rauszukicken über hier boah sehr gut
habe ich das gemacht
jeder einzelne Sound
lässt mich in der Vergangenheit schweben
und zeigt mir einfach ey du hast
wirklich irgendwie eine coole Kindheit
dass das so das Spiel war
was dann halt früher so gespielt hat
ey ich glaube ich fühle mich echt ein
bisschen ich glaube wenn ich dieses
Video hier Schneide denke ich mir auch
was du Trottel dieser Luca aber es ist
richtig schön gerade für mich wir hauen
den jetzt mal hier vorne raus weil ich
so ein paar andere Animationen sehen
will
nein also ich habe vier Punkte und mein
Gegner drei Punkte
[Musik]
dieser Sound nee
das ist so einfach wie früher
oh nein sehr gut
ey das ist so nice
es ist so schön jeder einzelne Sound es
ist so ein dummes Spiel
ich feier es komplett ne ich glaube es
ist wirklich vielleicht darf ich auch
nicht so viele selbst Zweifel haben hier
gerade an diesem Video aber Bruder es
ist jetzt kein Video was krass machen
wir das ist kein Video wo was sich Leute
zuschicken werden von wegen ey guck mal
krass voll witzig rausgehauen
aber solche Videos sind für mich einfach
cool auf einmal rausgehauen oh mein Gott
solche Videos sind für mich einfach
extrem cool weil ich die dann halt mit
in meinem Kanal so drin habe und
irgendwann wenn ich dann ICQ mal wieder
eingebe kommt vielleicht mal wieder ich
denke mal geil guck mal wie es gespielt
aber gut okay konzentrieren uns das
Spiel ich werde das ganze jetzt hier
gewinnen ich mache das nämlich jetzt
über die Bahn ich war früher richtig
krass in dem Spiel
[Musik]
oh mein Gott
das heißt ich muss jetzt treffen ist
aber auch nicht allzu schwer
ich habe gewonnen oh mein Gott auch
diese Animation es ist so ein
schrottspiel aber
das ist genauso glaube ich wie mit der
Heimat wenn man so und jetzt nicht aus
einer schönen Stadt kommt irgendwie
Hamburg München oder irgendwie sowas das
Heimatdorf oder die Stadt wo man
herkommt das kann man keinem anderen
erklären jeder den Test ganz normales
Dorf aber man selber verbindet mit jeder
Ecke irgendwie was mit jeder Laterne
verbindet man irgendwie was da bin ich
schon mal gegen gefahren da bin ich
schon mal drauf geklettert hier hatte
ich meinen ersten Kuss oder irgendwie so
und das ist keine Ahnung vielleicht bin
ich ein bisschen zu stylisch gerade wir
spielen heute allerdings nicht nur super
Lula sondern auch slide Lama und wir
spielen natürlich jetzt online gegen
einen anderen Spieler es sieht
wahrscheinlich für den ein oder anderen
gerade so aus als wäre das irgendwie ein
Glücksspiel oder irgendwie Casino oder
so ist es aber nicht man spielt die
nicht um Geld man muss nur drei in einer
Reihe haben und dafür kicke ich jetzt
beispielsweise einfach mal hin
wenn er seine Banane da reingekickt hat
er hier zum Beispiel drei bananas
und kriege ich dementsprechende Konto 20
Punkte drauf hier links an der Seite
sehen wir wie viel 300 Reihe immer so
bringen zum Beispiel hier so eine
Blaubeere rein und bekomme jetzt
logischerweise 30 Punkte weil die halt
30 Punkte bringen und dementsprechend
[Musik]
37 bringen 150 Punkte
verdammt ich habe euch das übrigens auch
mal unten in der Beschreibung verlinkt
also wenn ihr spielen wollt könnt ihr
einfach mal auf die Links in der
Beschreibung klicken ich habe mir jetzt
dreimal dieses Bar geholt da kriege ich
zumindest 100 Punkte also kann so ein
bisschen aufholen aber wenn ihr die
Spiele auch spielen wollt findet ihr
unten in der Beschreibung verlinkt ich
bin gerade auf sechs spiele.de früher
war man ja immer auf solchen Spiele
Webseiten unterwegs hat dann irgendwie
spielaffe oder irgendwie so ein Krams
genutzt hier kann ich jetzt leider keine
Punkte machen deswegen lege ich den
einfach mal hier oben drauf er kriegt
jetzt eine Birne danach habe ich wieder
eine sieben das heißt ich könnte
theoretisch wenn er das jetzt ein
bisschen verschiebt die Siebener nee
kriege ich nicht hin
[Musik]
ich muss jetzt halt überlegen weil er
hat auch eine sieben
[Musik]
ich war zu langsam nein
oh mein Gott wie soll ich denn das auf
der 320 Punkte hier rein
kriegen wir aber auch nur 20 Punkte
ich bin schon hart am Rhein Scheiße ne
er hat aber auch Glück was er für für
Blöcke zugeteilt bekommen guck mal hier
schon was soll ich mit Kirschen jetzt
machen hier
70 Punkte aber bin ich immer noch 100
Punkte hinter ihm
so unfair
guck mal und jetzt habe ich hier wieder
diese komische Glocke und Krieg einfach
bei drei Glocken ganz entspannt riesige
zehn Punkte
die Runde ist wirklich unfair bitte pack
die nicht hierhin nein nein nein nein
nein nicht hierhin nicht hierhin nicht
hin